first of all just gut check
stop anyone who's using the term surge
around you consciously is trying to
invoke a militaristic frame
this is not a surge these are children
and they are not insurgents and we are
not being
invaded
yeah well i would have to disagree with
alexandria ocasio-cortez we are being
invaded when you have hundreds of
thousands of people coming over
every month set to reach a million this
year that is an invasion and of course
everybody looks at those images
from these attention facilities and
feels very badly for those individuals
nobody would want to be in that position
but i will tell you this because i have
visited those facilities
i spent a lot of time with border patrol
agents and those that are
really tasked with their care i know
these images look bad
i know that's not what anybody wants to
see but you have to understand border
patrol asians
are being overwhelmed right now they're
being relegated to babysitters they're
not able to do their actual jobs
and they're doing the best that they can
with the resources that they have
so we need to come together as a nation
and decide how we're going to get border
patrol better resources
but as john james said at the top of
this block what we really need to be
doing is stop incentivizing people to
come over here
these are children yes they are
absolutely they are innocent children
but they are being incentivized to come
over here their parents are sending them
over here they know that they will only
be held for a certain amount of days
possibly move to a convention center be
given schooling housing
and then they'll be released into the
shadows and then eventually the parents
will be allowed to come right along with
them
if they're not already in this country
so we have to stop
incentivizing it but i will disagree
with some of the points that were made
as far as
that nobody has tackled this problem
donald j trump tackled this problem his
zero tolerance policy his policy that
said
do not come over here if you do not want
to be separated do not cross that border
illegally
do not come we are building a wall we
are taking immigration seriously we have
every right
to protect and defend the integrity of
our border that
was working then the biden
administration came in with their virtue
signaling
and threw that all away and now
everybody suffers the migrant children
suffer
the american taxpayer suffers and we're
in this dilemma that has no end in sight
but it has to start with securing the
border
jillian your floor
so first of all i would say
if president biden woke up tomorrow
and did what every republican lawmaker
and every trump supporter wants him to
do
which is to reinstate the remaining
mexico policy
what would happen to the tens of
thousands
of children in particular families but
unaccompanied minors most specifically
who would then be
left on the mexico side of the u.s
southern border i
understand opposition to biden
administration policies i hear them loud
and clear but my question for a lot of
people who are
sort of critiquing the situation right
now is
there's a lot of coulda woulda shoulda
but we always have to accept reality for
what it is
the biden administration has reversed
the reign in mexico policy so what
happens
now if you refuse to admit thousands of
unaccompanied minors into the united
states
do they live happily ever after or are
they now stranded on the mexico side of
the u.s southern border
and more become more vulnerable to sex
traffickers and coyotes
and the cartels what people need to i
think this is
obviously shannon would never pretend to
speak to you
to speak for you but i think this is
what you were getting at when you were
talking about we need
solutions we need less critique and more
accepting of the reality and people
getting on board to try and figure out
solutions because as tommy says this is
not just about those migrants
this is about the health and well-being
of all americans too so i'd like to hear
some more people putting their heads
together to the problem instead of just
complaining about it all the time
well hopefully the bridge between
candidate kamala harris and vice
president
kamala harris becomes crossable and she
should find some of those solutions now
that she's
in charge of the whole thing of course
starting with diplomacy
we will not hold our breath